Jamie is in Michigan hi Jamie what's up
oh man I'm so happy to still be
available for listening to you and
getting your advice and help through
this tough time what a blessing you are
Thank You Darla how can we help today
I'm gonna try to keep it together I'm
sorry I'm emotional
that's okay good thank you
I've been a long time anybody sufferers
I'm also pregnant with my third baby
well that might that might make it big
time that's right for sure
I've been a stay-at-home mom for a few
years my husband works we're blessed
enough that he is able to support us but
that kind of leave me to my fear and
anxiety currently he's part of the
essential supply chain just doing what
he does he's a Salesman and I'm also
immunocompromised just by my own health
condition of being pregnant we've been
following you since July last year and
we been bustin into the videos on
YouTube and I know that we've been
hadn't been to put a hold on baby step
two once we found out we were pregnant
and you know just piling up cherish so
we kind of were blessed where we were
able to kind of sir see this coming and
I told my husband you know go out and
buy these things because I know people
are gonna freak out we're not hoarders
by any means I'm just a planner how much
toilet paper of you got really Jamie I'm
messing with you how can we best help
you today no I'm just so full of fear
just because you've got to go out and
I'm just
worried every day is this today the day
of wires huh Oh Ashley okay and also
like financially it's kind of like we're
just every day is that are you gonna be
considered a part of the vital force and
I mean he's just a wine salesman how
essential is that you say a wine
salesman correct
he sells wine and able to support our
family I think of no more important job
on planet earth right now a wine
salesman hey so let me let me talk to
inter Jamie this is John de Loney
and I'm not as handsome as Dave here but
can I ask you to what's the what's the
name of this third maybe gonna be Paris
Faris correct yeah
when winds winds Faris do thank you so
despite all the anxiety all the fear can
we do one thing together can you tell me
one thing you're super excited about
getting to meet Faris well I'm excited
for them to be healthy there you go
Faris is gonna be healthy Faris is gonna
be born healthy and I want you to
continue to celebrate the the gift and
beautiful beautiful addition to your
family that Faris is gonna be I grew up
in the home of a responder my dad was a
cop and a SWAT team guy
my wife has grown up in that home and so
I know exactly I've lived in that home
of that fear of his today gonna be the
day right it's today gonna be the day
and a wine salesman is probably not
gonna get shot or wine salesman's
product to be directly in contact with
some of these things but I do understand
sitting at home and wondering is today
gonna be the day and so what I want to
encourage you to do as much as possible
is to give yourself a routine to take
care of the other two kids that are
probably yeah are you homeschooling now
suddenly are you homeschool mom to now
yeah I got a third grader home and a
toddler so congratulations there you go
so I'm gonna strongly recommend you make
a plan and routine that you honor your
body and that
you exercise that you eat as help as you
can do the things that you can control
and when those thoughts of what if what
if he gets laid off what if he brings
this home what if you take there take
the precautions that the CDC is putting
out there take the precautions at your
local government put out there but most
importantly don't dwell on the fear well
here what's your OB saying about
coronavirus with pregnancy they like to
defer to the CDC guidelines on
everything that's what everybody's doing
right that they're just passing that
passing the buck around CDC owns our
soul now that's right so your home
doctor won't give you guidelines
that's ridiculous okay yeah they're kind
of deferring you know my GP wants to
defer to my OB who wants a deferred as a
PDC so I'm in a game of acronyms
you can make some alphabet soup while
you're home yeah and I've got folks I've
got friends and my community Jamie that
are out taking their clothes off on the
back porch however bad that is for the
neighbors to have to see and they are
washing their clothes before they come
in and others that are just choosing to
not hug and kiss their kids until they
go to get a shower so everybody's
handling it differently
I recommend again I'm sorry that your
local doctor isn't giving you more
guidance on this but the most important
thing is you can't live you can't make
the air in your home that you're going
to breathe this one of fear and might
happen
negative negative reactions right really
lean into the positive you've got a baby
on the way it's going to be another
beautiful addition to your home your
husband has a job he's yeah he's
employed he's employed today and no
one's got the virus today these are
facts that's right but this is real well
that's what's real right and you know
it's hard to concentrate on that I
always tell you there's nothing wrong
with you
in your third trimester with your third
kid with a single income in the
household having anxiety that would make
you like a normal human being
that's exactly right most people would
have anxiety in this situation and so
that's okay that you have some all we're
doing is walking through with with dr. D
here how to you know how to manage that
and say I'm going to control what I can
control the rest is in God's hands and
not in an irresponsible way or
crazy way or I'm gonna jump off a cliff
and it's in God's hands if I can fly
that's not what we're saying
but yeah there are saying you do what
you do what you can do and you've done
all you can do that's right and Jamie
also mentioned she's been struggling
with anxiety for years yeah and if she
does have a mental health provider I was
notified last night that there's
multiple states are opening up
tella mental health services so get with
your local therapist that you've been
with in the past and take care of
yourself